california es el único lugar del mundo
donde puedes ir con una camisa hawaiana
y unas botas lejanas sin que nadie se te
quede mirando no solo es el estado más
grande de eeuu sino también el más rico
es más si lo comparas 'hemos con el
resto de países del mundo sería la sexta
economía del planeta por encima de
españa francia o méxico y precisamente
por eso os va a sorprender si os digo
que california tiene una crisis de deuda
tan bestial como la de españa o grecia
tal cual el mismo sitio donde está
silicon valley donde está hollywood
donde la gente practica el surf como si
no existiera mañana en ese mismo lugar
el gobierno ha tenido que recortar los
sueldos de los funcionarios cerrar
escuelas y hasta algunos se ha llegado a
preguntar si serían capaces de pagar las
pensiones de los jubilados flipante
verdad
en los últimos dos años parece que el
gobernador del estado jerry brown ha
sido capaz de poner un parche a este
problema de deuda pero todavía queda
muchas dudas abiertas es una solución
pasajera volveremos a ver a los
californianos caer por el abismo de la
deuda hoy vamos a responder a todas esas
preguntas pero antes os vamos a mostrar
esa california que nos sale en las
películas
porque hay tanta desigualdad en
california california es la región con
más desigualdad de todo eeuu
si todos conocemos las empresas de
silicon valley de hecho esta zona es una
de las más ricas del mundo con un
salario medio de más de 55 mil dólares
al año pero 100 kilómetros más allá está
central valley donde el sueldo medio no
llega ni a la mitad 3 actualmente en el
sur de california hay 32 millones de
personas viviendo por debajo del nivel
federal y pobre y ojo todo esto teniendo
en cuenta que california tiene muchísimo
más programas sociales que el resto del
país y que su sistema fiscal está
pensado para que paguen más quienes más
tienen
por cierto esto tan bonito que está
sonando es la música que nos ha
compuesto mikel bilbao exclusivamente
para este canal
entonces por qué hay tanta desigualdad
lo primero que hay que tener en cuenta
es que california es el hogar de muchas
de las grandes fortunas del mundo lo
segundo es que el 30 por ciento de la
población son inmigrantes y muchos de
estos nuevos ciudadanos tienen trabajos
mal remunerados y no pueden acceder a
las ayudas públicas que ofrece el estado
los que seguís visual polític desde hace
tiempo recordaréis este vídeo en el que
os contábamos cómo los inmigrantes
concretamente los latinoamericanos
progresan muy rápidamente pero mientras
lo hacen conforman ese grupo de
población que está por debajo de la
media media que por otra parte está
artificialmente inflada por el efecto de
estas grandes fortunas pero la principal
razón por la cual hay tanta desigualdad
en california es su ley de vivienda que
es una de las más restrictivas de todo
eeuu
y construir una casa en california es
prácticamente imposible
necesitas muchísimas licencias y además
el suelo está tan regulado que apenas
queda espacio libre para hacer obras
nuevas conclusión en california es
carísimo comprar una casa para que os
hagáis una idea en el condado de orange
el precio medio de la vivienda está por
encima de los 600 mil dólares
en coste astronómico de la vivienda en
california está llevando a muchas
familias a la pobreza es decir que cada
vez hay más diferencia entre aquellos
que han nacido en california y que
pudieron comprar una vivienda hace 30
años y aquellos que la tienen que
comprar ahora esto significa unos
beneficios extraordinarios para los
propietarios y todo esto también se nota
en los alquileres un apartamento
pequeñito en san francisco nos costaría
unos dos mil trescientos dólares al mes
y el sueldo de una empleada en una
tienda normal estaría entre los dos mil
novecientos así que hacer las cuentas y
qué hace el gobierno para evitar tanta
desigualdad pues crear más y más
programas sociales y esta es la primera
razón para explicar
en california tuvo una crisis de deuda
california gasta cada año en sanidad más
del doble de lo que gasta texas y lo
mismo ocurre en pensiones programas
sociales viviendas de protección oficial
subvenciones etcétera los que veáis este
vídeo desde españa no os sorprenderéis
mucho porque en europa estamos
acostumbrados a que el gobierno gaste
mucho en el estado del bienestar pero
para lo que es el estándar de eeuu
california es con diferencia el estado
que más gasta
y os preguntaréis está mal que un
gobierno gaste mucho en estado del
bienestar pues no tiene por qué pero ese
dinero tiene que venir de algún sitio y
ese sitio son los impuestos en eeuu
tenemos por un lado los impuestos
federales que son iguales en todas
partes y por el otro los impuestos
estatales que en cada sitio son de un
padre y una madre por ejemplo en texas
no tienen impuesto sobre la renta y todo
depende del impuesto sobre las ventas
que sería algo así como el iva sin
embargo en california es todo lo
contrario el líbano llega al 8% y el
impuesto de viviendas es muy bajo sin
embargo el impuesto sobre la renta es el
más alto de todo el país y el 48% de la
recaudación viene de ese 1% más
y os preguntaréis dónde está el problema
en principio es buena idea que paguen
más quienes más tienen verdad pues
tenéis razón pero ojo también tiene sus
inconvenientes normalmente los ingresos
de los ricos no vienen de su sueldo sino
de las rentas del capital es decir sus
inversiones
una persona como marc zuckerberg no es
millonaria porque tengo un sueldo muy
alto en facebook sino porque es el
propietario de buena parte de las
acciones de la empresa y esto qué
significa es que cuando la economía va
bien mark zuckerberg pagará muchos
impuestos pero si por lo que sea un año
facebook no da beneficios apenas pagarán
a la conclusión que california recauda
mucho o muy poco dependiendo de cómo
esté el ciclo económico para que lo
veáis mejor vamos a comparar las
fluctuaciones de los impuestos de
california con los de un país tan
estable como puede ser suecia
este valle que veis aquí corresponde a
la crisis del 2009 tanto al gobierno
sueco como el californiano recaudaron
mucho menos ese año pero si os dais
cuenta en suecia la caída es mucho menos
pronunciada porque pues porque la
recaudación del estado sueco depende
mucho de otros impuestos como las ventas
la vivienda o los sueldos de los
trabajadores al depender de distintas
fuentes los ingresos son mucho más
equilibrados y estables sin embargo
cuando las cosas en california fueron
mal para su gobierno fueron
rematadamente mal y esto significa que
no había dinero para pagar todo ese
gasto social
con una crisis de liquidez asomándose y
una crisis fiscal cada vez más profunda
california empezará a emitir deuda hoy
mismo
el gobernador del estado que por aquel
entonces era nuestro querido amigo
arnold schwarzenegger intentar recortar
gasto donde pudo congeló las pensiones
de los funcionarios recortó los sueldos
de los maestros y por supuesto cerró
todas las obras que estaban
presupuestadas y mientras tanto intentó
tapar todos los agujeros del presupuesto
con deuda pública por suerte la economía
en california está lo suficientemente
diversificada como para que una crisis
del gobierno no se traduzca en una
destrucción de su tejido empresarial
pero lo cierto es que cuando se hacen
ayer pasó el testigo al demócrata jerry
brown en el año 2012
california tenía una deuda más grande
que la de grecia
durante estos próximos cuatro años vamos
a equilibrar las cuentas ya vivir dentro
de nuestras posibilidades y que ha hecho
jerry brown desde entonces pues
continuar la política de recortes de
schwarzenegger y además subir los
impuestos pero ojo
sin cambiar el sistema fiscal de
california es decir que la recaudación
todavía depende en muy buena medida de
las rentas del capital y aquí es donde
surge la división de opiniones porque
los muy partidarios del partido
demócrata
dicen que gerry brownlee california son
todo un modelo para salir de la crisis
el éxito de jerry brown es una lección
para los demócratas a nivel nacional
pero también hay muchos críticos que
dicen que sí que como el ciclo económico
ha estado muy bien en los últimos dos
años en eeuu
jerry brown ha conseguido poner un
parche a la crisis de deuda pero que en
cuanto a las cosas vuelvan a ir mal el
gobierno de california lo volverá a
pasar muy mal
moody's la agencia de 'rating' ha
preparado una lista con los estados
menos preparados para afrontar otra
recesión y california estaba en el peor
lugar sólo superada por illinois y la
pregunta es debería california cambiar
su sistema fiscal podrían aprender algo
de las economías de los países europeos
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y si os interesa saber más
sobre la economía de distintos países
suscribiros a visual político y
seguirnos en nuestras redes sociales
podéis encontrarnos todos los lunes y
jueves en youtube y por supuesto los
domingos en la vanguardia.com si os ha
gustado el vídeo
'nadie a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta la próxima